hi everyone thank you for having me
my name is kim holden and i am a
research associate at labcorp and i'm
based in san diego california
today i'll be going through an
instrument evaluation we performed at
labcorp with the eurogene health coastal
genomics automated size selection
platform
we found that size selection of
cell-free dna enhances signal for the
detection of tumor-specific variants in
cancer patients
today i will go over some background
information on current challenges in
circulating tumor dna variant detection
our method for quantifying copy number
alterations using the genome instability
number or gin
utilizing cfdna fragment size
the purpose of size selection
and the your jane health size selection
platforms
next i'll go over some general methods
including the size selection parameters
we used for this study
and copy number alteration
quantification methods
then our i will present our results from
this study and finally our conclusions
from this evaluation
so first i'll go over some background
information
cell free dna or cf dna are degraded dna
fragments released into blood plasma
and circulating tumor dna or ct dna is a
category of cfdna derived from tumor
tissue
cfdna has many applications
including prenatal testing oncology
transplant monitoring among many others
ctdna is present at very low abundance
it can be below 0.5 percent of total cf
dna
and that typically increases with
advancing disease
demonstrated in this figure on the right
studies have shown that as ct dna
concentration increases the two-year
survival probability decreases
demonstrating the need for early disease
detection
in patients with slow tumor burden for
example an early disease stage or
certain cancer types
it is often difficult to detect
tumor-derived variants
to overcome these limitations methods
have been developed to better
distinguish the ct dna signal from the
noise we encounter in most current
methodologies
while these solutions are successful in
minimizing the technical noise
it often requires increased sequencing
depth and other advanced analytical
techniques
the genome instability number or gin is
a metric we developed to quantify the
cumulative deviation of all autosomal
copy number alterations
to quantify the level of genomic
instability
it's influenced by both the magnitude of
the cna and the level of ct dna
a higher gen indicates more significant
cnas
and our current threshold to indicate a
high level of genomic instability is a
gin value above 170.
in the figures on the right each data
point represents a 50 kilobase segment
of the human genome and colors alternate
by chromosome
the empirically derived euploid genome
is where relative representation
is equal to
one deviations above that line indicate
an over representation of cf dna
fragments from that region and values
below indicate a loss
this figure shows two whole genome
profiles from the same patient both
before and after a tumor removal surgery
you can see that there are many
deviations before surgery which is
represented by a gin value of almost
2000
and after tumor removal surgery the
genome falls back into a normal profile
with gin equal to 153 which is below the
threshold of 170.
to determine the limit of detection for
gin we first established the analytical
specificity using 27
754 prenatal patients with no reported
cnas
with a gin cost at 170 99.7
of samples were found to have no
evidence of genomic instability
then to determine the analytical
sensitivity
four cancer cell lines were spiked into
a healthy background sample at varying
percentages from 1 to 25
using a gin threshold of 170 we were
able to detect 4 out of 12 samples that
were spiked in at one percent
and all cell line samples when they were
spiked in at two percent or higher
therefore we estimated gin sensitivity
to be between one and two percent tumor
dna
we wanted to find a way to improve the
limit of detection for the gin assay and
detecting copy number alterations
so we utilized the cfdna fragment size
the median length of cfdna from healthy
tissue is typically around 167 base
pairs
the rosenfeld lab at the university of
cambridge published a study on utilizing
fragment size analysis to enhance the
detection of circulating tumor dna
they demonstrated that in cancer types
with typically higher fractions of
circulating tumor dna
such as breast or lung cancers
there were significantly higher
proportions of fragments shorter than
150 base pairs when compared to healthy
donors or cancer types with typically
low amounts of ct dna such as renal or
bladder cancers
this indicates that tumor-derived cfdna
fragments are on average shorter than
cfdna fragments derived from healthy
tissue
in current workflows samples are
typically not size selected prior to
sequencing
so there are large fractions of wild
type or normal fragments that are
processed alongside tumor fragments
there are multiple ways to perform size
selection either in silico using
paradigm sequencing or several methods
of physical separation
size selection increases the tumor
fraction of the sample and can enrich
signal for the detection of
tumor-specific variants
which can reduce sequencing depths and
costs and improve the limit of detection
in cancer patients enriching for
tumor-specific dna can be useful for
early disease detection
or for predicting disease progression in
patients with typically low amounts of
ct dna
this figure demonstrates the
representation of the cfdna fragments in
a cancer patient
the pool before size selection on the
left contains a large fraction of
wild-type cf dna fragments
which have a median length of around 167
base pairs
there are few tumor cf dna fragments
which have a median length less than 167
base pairs
as an example the tumor fraction of this
sample before size selection is 10
performing size selection removed some
wild type fragments while retaining the
tumor fragments and resulted in a
greater proportion of tumor fragments
relative to wild type and increased the
tumor fraction to 20 percent
so next i'll do a brief over
health platforms for size selection
the eurogene health dye selection
platforms utilize a combination of
ranger technology and hamilton robotics
ranger technology is an automated means
of size selecting dna with agarose gel
electrophoresis via machine vision
these images show the illumination stage
where blue and red lights illuminate the
marker and sample bias
the camera takes images of both colors
at various points throughout the
electrophoresis
allowing for the instrument software to
determine the sample size and adjust
each lane voltage accordingly
these images show the electrophoresis
pedestal where the gel cassettes are
placed and imaged on the instrument
each cassette can run 12 samples
simultaneously and voltage is adjusted
for each lane individually
the cassettes contain an in-channel
filter to separate fragment sizes
allowing for a more precise size
selection
your chain health currently has two size
selection platforms available
the first is the nimbus select which is
a fully automated gel size selection
platform
it has a 96 channel capacity with around
100 minute runtime
the second instrument is the light bench
which can be used as a standalone
instrument or be integrated with
automation
this instrument has a 12 channel
capacity and around 45 minute runtime
ranger technology boasts
industry-leading performance
specifications for short dna fragment
size selection
with more than 97 repeatability
95 accuracy and 70 average intrinsic
recovery
so next i will review the methods for
these experiments
the same methods were used for each of
the five experiments performed in this
instrument evaluation of the your jean
health size selection platform
adapter ligated libraries were sent to
your gene health for size selection
targeting a cf dna insert size of 142
base pairs
samples were normalized and sequenced on
the illumina high seek 2500
and data were processed using methods
originally developed for detecting copy
number alterations in prenatal patients
based on previous studies of the length
of tumor-derived sea of dna we wanted to
aim for a library cutoff of around 302
base pairs
your gene health platforms have a sizing
range buffer of about 15 base pairs
around the target
so in this electro ferrogram trace
example i highlighted the target region
in green
and the upper buffer range area in red
adjusting for an adapter length of 160
base pairs we're targeting a cf dna
insert size of 142 base pairs
something that we did not implement
during testing that can be added is a
lower bound cutoff to remove adapter
dimers
i used two metrics throughout this
analysis to quantify copy number
alterations
first the genome instability number
utilizes normalized sequencing reads
that are mapped to the human reference
genome and partitioned into 50 kb
non-overlapping segments
it is intended to capture genome-wide
autosomal deviation from empirically
derived euploid dosage of the genome in
circulation
it is a non-negative continuous value
calculated as the absolute deviation of
observed normalized sequencing rate
coverage summed across 50 034 autosomal
segments
observed normalized rate coverage is
defined for each genomic segment by an
autism-specific lowest fit of the
normalized data
increasing values of gin are indicative
of increasing deviation relative to an
expected normal genomic profile
second the area under the curve or auc
was calculated for each detected copy
number alteration to determine the
deviation of individual cnas from
expected
cnas were only analyzed for each sample
if they were detected both before and
after size selection
the auc ratio was subsequently
calculated by dividing the auc of a cna
after size selection
by the auc of that same cna before size
selection
in addition to quantifying cnas see if
dna fragment length was also obtained
from paired and sequencing data
and finally after size selection the
cutoff size for each sample was
determined by calculating the point at
which the normalized recovery of the
sample
shifted from greater than 50 recovered
to less than 50 recovered
essentially marking the point at which
the gel electrophoresis was stopped and
the sample was extracted from the
collection filter
next i'm going to go through the results
from each of the five experiments
throughout this evaluation
and then some overall trends in the data
our first experiment was performed to
test the feasibility of using the your
jean health instruments for size
selection
and to evaluate the consistency of the
size selection
the figure on the top right shows the
proportion of total sequencing reads at
each fragment length between zero and
five hundred base pairs
the first question is in red and after
size selection is in blue
you can see that the size selection was
successful and the fragment length
profile after size selection has shifted
towards the smaller end
the figure on the bottom right shows the
proportion of fragment sizes less than
167 base pairs in yellow
and less than 150 base pairs in blue
before size selection is shown on the
left and after size selection on the
right
as expected before size selection we saw
about 50 of reeds below 167 base pairs
and about 25
below 150 base pairs
after size selection over 99 percent of
reads were below 167 base pairs and 97
below 150 base pairs
this sample set had an average size
selection cutoff of 141 base pairs and
the cutoff size cv was 3.7
these initial results were promising so
we wanted to add some additional samples
to our data set
sample set 2 was intended to increase
our sample size and gather additional
data
particularly for cancer patient samples
what was immediately obvious to us as
you can see in the figure on the top
right
there were two issues
the first being the large fragment
carryover shown in the circled region
and the second being size cutoff
inconsistency which had a much larger
range than the previous sample set
after size selection we were seeing 95
percent of reads below 167 base pairs
and 90 below 150 base pairs
the average cutoff size was much lower
at 130 base pairs
but the cutoff size cv was 8.5 percent
after working with your gene health to
troubleshoot these issues we came up
with two separate causes for these
problems
the large fragment carryover was
determined to be from manufacturing
issues with the cassettes
and the cutoff size variation was due to
using markers that were outside the
range of our target cutoff
we had originally chosen these markers
when we were intending to use cfdna
rather than libraries as our starting
material
and did not want the markers to be
amplified alongside the sea of dna in
our libraries
but a different marker set was more
appropriate to use for these libraries
after seeing these variabilities we
wanted to make some adjustments to our
protocol to ensure we could get a
consistent size selection and keep the
cv low
experiment 3 was meant to test the
solutions to the two issues found in
experiment two
protein health implemented the
manufacturing changes to their cassettes
and we used more appropriate markers for
our cutoff target
the consistency was much better with the
cutoff size cv at less than one percent
but the cutoff size was larger than we
wanted with an average of 153 base pairs
after size selection 98 of reads were
below 167 base pairs and 80 was below
150 base pairs
we wanted to run a follow-up experiment
to this to ensure we could lower our
cutoff size to an average of about 142
base pairs
so experiment 4 was intended to be a
quick experiment to make sure we could
make the change to the cob size to meet
our target
i provided only healthy libraries that
were generated from cfdna extracted from
pooled plasma of many healthy
individuals
the libraries themselves were then
pooled and split into 12 size selection
reactions
the figure on the top right shows that
the libraries were extremely consistent
before size selection and had very low
variability after size selection
over 98 percent of reads were below 150
base pairs after size selection
and the cutoff size average was 137 base
pairs with a cv of 1.2 percent
since these samples were all pooled
plasma from healthy patients we wanted
to run a final experiment to introduce
real patient samples
and ensure we could keep the cutoff size
and cv low
as well as keep a consistent fragment
size profile with minimal carryover
so in this final experiment we provided
more challenging samples from cancer
patients to verify the size cost and
consistency in a more realistic set of
patient samples
once again we saw over 98 of reeds below
150 base pairs and had an average cutoff
size of 135 base pairs with a cv of 2.2
percent
the results from this experiment showed
that the urging health size selection
instruments can reliably and accurately
size select our libraries
to summarize all five experiments which
included 58 samples from healthy
patients and 40 samples from cancer
patients libraries prior to size
selection had an average median cfdna
fragment size of 169 base pairs in
healthy patients
and 165 base pairs in cancer patients
after size selection the average median
fee of dna fragment sizes were
significantly lower
at 127 base pairs for healthy patients
and 120 base pairs for cancer patients
we also wanted to quantify copy number
alterations before and after size
selection
to see if we were enriching the signal
in cancer patients while maintaining the
signal for healthy patients
this figure shows a genome profile of a
healthy patient with a couple of
probable germline copy number
alterations
the top portion shows the profile before
size selection where gin equals 94.3
and the copy number alteration on
chromosome 3 has an auc of 3.75
the bottom portion shows the profile
after size selection where gin equals
189.8
and that same copy number alteration has
an auc of 3.6
it's likely that the increase in noise
indicated by the wider band in the size
selected sample is causing gin to shift
above our threshold but that can likely
be mitigated by retraining the analysis
pipeline
alternatively this figure shows the
genome profile of a cancer patient
the top portion shows this patient's
profile before size selection
gin is over 1300 and one of the copy
number alterations on chromosome
you see of 35.8
after size selection is shown on the
bottom
gin nearly doubled to over 2500
and the same cna has an auc of 70.1
which is 1.95 times greater than before
size selection
this figure shows the auc ratios from
all cnas detected both before and after
size selection in all patients
an auc ratio value equal to 1 indicates
no difference in cna detection after
size selection
an auc value greater than 1 indicates an
increase in signal for the cna after
size selection and a value less than 1
indicates a decrease in signal
when evaluating cfdna from healthy
patients
30 cnas were found both before and after
size selection
the average auc ratio was 1.04
which is consistent with a lack of
signal enrichment in the absence of
disease
in cancer patients
237 cnas were detected before and after
size selection
and the average auc ratio was 1.99
which is consistent with an enrichment
of
signal a healthy patient with probable
germline cnas is shown in this example
panel a on the top left shows the
genome-wide profile of the sample before
size selection
which in equals 115.2
panel b on the bottom left shows the
genome wide profile of the sample after
size selection which in equals 164.5
panel c shows the fragment size profile
of the sample before and after size
selection
the median fragment length after size
selection was 138 base pairs whereas the
median before size selection was 170
base pairs and panel d shows the paired
analysis of the absolute value of the
auc for a total of four cnas detected
before and after size selection
the auc does not change significantly
after size selection indicated by an
average auc ratio of 1.19
this indicates that enrichment of
shorter cfdna fragments does not affect
signal from probable germline cnas
there also seem to be some cancer
patients where size selection does not
enhance the cna signal
the genome profiles before and after
size selection shows some larger cnas in
chromosomes 1 8 and 12 being the most
obvious
channel c shows that size selection was
successful with a median fragment size
of 166 base pairs before size selection
and 116 base pairs after size selection
there were four cnas detected both
before and after size selection in this
patient with an average auc ratio of
1.02
and we would likely need some additional
clinical data from these patients with
little or no enrichment to understand
the underlying causes for these patterns
and as we saw from the fragment size
profiles especially from experiment 2
there was some variability in the actual
cutoff sizes so these next figures show
samples with varying cutoff sizes
in this cancer patient sample we
achieved a size selection cutoff of 152
base pairs
panel a on the top left shows the
genome-wide profile of the sample before
size selection
origin equals 716.6
panel b on the bottom left shows the
genome-wide profile of the sample after
size selection
where cnas increased a small amount in
magnitude and the gin increased to
1201.5
channel c on the top right shows the
cfdna fragment size profile for the
sample before and after size selection
the median fragment length after size
selection was 148 base pairs whereas the
median before size selection was 167
base pairs
since the magnitude of the difference in
fragment sizes is relatively small there
is still considerable overlap in the
fragment size distribution between
conditions for this sample
panel d on the bottom right shows paired
analysis of the absolute value of the
auc for a total of 30 cnas detected
before and after size selection
there was significant enrichment of
cna's after size selection
indicated by an average auc ratio of 1.7
a lower size selection cutoff of 116
base pairs is shown in this cancer
patient example
panel a and b again show the genome-wide
profiles of the samples before and after
size selection
and you can visually see that cnas
increased significantly in magnitude and
the gin also increased significantly
to over 2300 after size selection
some examples of cnas can be seen on
chromosomes 2 and 7 where the entire
chromosomes are amplified after size
selection
channel c shows the cfdna fragment size
profile of this sample before and after
size selection the median fragment
length after size selection was 9
whereas the median before size selection
was 116 166 base pairs
since the magnitude of the difference in
fragment sizes is large there is very
little overlap in the fragment size
distribution between conditions for this
sample
panel d shows paired analysis of the
absolute value of the auc for a total of
18 cnas detected before and after size
selection
there was significant enrichment of
cna's after size selection indicated by
an average auc ratio of 3.7
so finally i will go over some
limitations from this study and our
conclusions from this instrument
evaluation
so one of the limitations of this study
was the auc calculation
it was a manual process and to be able
to accurately compare a specific cna
before and after size selection i
sometimes had to merge multiple bin
segments together and calculate an
overall auc for the merge segments
further method development they may be
necessary to indicate the significance
of those cnas
the second limitation while we had a
decent sized sample set with 58 healthy
samples and 40 cancer samples
each experiment had its own unique set
of parameters that were changed so
collecting more data using a consistent
protocol would give us more confidence
in our results
and the third limitation was that these
patients had various types of cancers in
different stages and different
treatments so digging into the clinical
data might allow us to draw some
additional conclusions
some overall trends we observed in this
data set include the median see if dna
fragment size significantly decreased
after size selection
additionally cnas increase in magnitude
after size selection for cancer patients
and not for healthy patients
lower cutoff sizes increase cna signal
further than higher cutoff sizes in some
cancer patients but this is not true for
all patients
and we do want to keep in mind a balance
between going shorter and having enough
material to sequence
and finally after troubleshooting with
your gene health we determined that size
selection using the nimbus select or the
light bench can
enhance the signal for the detection of
tumor-specific variants in cancer
patients
i want to thank my supervisor taylor
jensen for support and guidance
throughout this project
carrie fitzgerald helped with some of
the lab work for these experiments
jojun processed all of the sequencing
data and the overall lab court
bioinformatics team helped develop the
pipeline
jared and matt on the origin health team
provided or performed the size selection
on their instruments and were incredibly
helpful as we were troubleshooting the
process
and finally nate and graham provided me
with all of the samples used in this
study
thank you very much for attending my
talk and i am happy to take any
questions you have for me via email
thank you